these scientists with the Charles Darwin
foundation have spent the last 12 hours
on a ship now they're off to look for
penguins on the Galapagos Island of
Isabella the islands are home to the
only penguins found in the Northern
Hemisphere as well as the green ocean
turtle which is facing extinction the
biodiversity on these volcanic islands
is unique but climate change is taking
its toll many species are finding their
food sources in short supply and that's
affecting reproduction the last time
these scientists visited they marked
nests to facilitate counting the local
penguin population they estimate that
it's barely a thousand one of the
biggest threats is the El Nino climate
pattern it causes extreme weather and
rising temperatures problem is commute
the problem is that climate change is
making a ninya more frequent and what's
worse it's making a linear even stronger
than it used to be the result is that
the penguin population has declined
dramatically and recuperar see the giant
tortoise is also endemic to the
Galapagos Islands they can live to be
170 years old
the Galapagos tortoise limbs off grass
herbs and cactus but if it can't find
enough food
it stops reproducing things aren't yet
that bad the Charles Darwin foundation
is working in collaboration with the
National Park Galapagos to set up more
breeding stations Ecuador is making the
preservation of this unique ecosystem a
priority the tortoises are released into
the wild once they're five years old but
protecting individual species to
protecting entire ecosystems the most
important species for the Galapagos
Islands ecosystem is the tortoise sea
Malakian
it's at the top of the food chain of
herbivores here on the Galapagos Islands
meanwhile the human population is
growing in the last 30 years it's
increased tenfold there are now around
thirty thousand inhabitants here and
they're joined by about 180,000 tourists
every year this also affects the local
wildlife Snatcher habitat there's a
growing demand for energy like here on
the island of Floreana smallest
inhabited Galapagos Island in the past
it relied entirely on diesel for its
energy needs but that's changing these
days Floriana is switching to generators
powered with vegetable oil this
production plant was built with German
help it's a pilot project supported by
the international climate initiative
jatropha oil is delivered from the
mainland this form of almost completely
climate neutral energy production is a
model for other galapagos islands it
marks a major step forward in climate
protection
the scarp here after enzo knew this
place used to only have power for just
four hours a day diesel fuel was
transported in tanks in metal barrels
and then pumped into dilapidated tanks
at the port they leaked and the diesel
was a serious pollutant these are our
scofflaw Sinise in your belt the added
bonus of using jatropha oil is that it
boosts farmers income in mainland
Ecuador the coastal region of Manabi is
one of the poorest in the world these
days local farmers are harvesting
jatropha curcas destined for the
Galapagos Islands previously they didn't
bother it can't be used as food because
its seeds are poisonous but now that
they can sell a sack of jatropha seeds
for $13 it's worth the effort
the plant is resistant to drought and
pests and its seeds contain an average
of 34 percent oil making it ideal for
power generation
but chattri Pasillas haven't been a
quick fix the quality of the harvests
was initially problematic and the oil in
sufficiently pure special filters needed
to be installed and farmers needed
training these days the quality is much
improved demote or ask a lot the engines
here in the Galapagos Islands are very
modern have to meet very strict emission
standards the quality of the fuel has to
be very high and Manabi is in a position
to supply this high-quality Dietzen
throttle even
it looks like a storm is brewing the
research ship is now taking the German
experts to another part of the isabella
island
Gustavo Jimenez a veterinarian and an
expert on penguins expects they'll
establish that the penguin population
has declined again since the last count
the experts locate the nests they marked
using GPS later they'll assess their
findings and discuss what protective
measures they need to take to curb the
trend time is running out and the little
galapagos penguin could be facing
extinction
you